une pause de son travail
pour sortir au parc avec
son garçon de 3 ans et demi.
qui s'ajoute, son CPE aura au
total fermé ses portes 10 ururs
depuis le début de l'automne.
de famille  monoparentale,
c'est un casse-tête dtrtrouver
des solutions de gardiennage.
- C'est la famille. Bon, on a
qui l'a gardé depuis qu'il est
tout petit, donc je lui ai
demandé un peu d'aide
le cercle habituel d'aid
qui est mis à contribution puis
pour pas non plus surcharger.
- Après les absences causées par
des nez qui coulent et des
fermetures de groupes en raison
de la covid, de nombreux parents
nous disent être à bout
- C'est plus entre mères qu'on
se parle, ananananananananananae
assez épuisées de l'automne
qu'on a. On est un peuchacun da,
puis que a devient difficile de
parents pour faire porter...
pour que notre voix porte au
gouvernement pour leur dire :
il faut trouver une solution.
- Ce qui stagne, ce sont
les discussions sur
les augmentations salariales
du personnel de so C C C C C C t
des postes d'entretien,
d'adjoint administratif,eeeeeeee
et de responsables
en alimentation.les menus et pr,
qui changent au gré des saisons,
dans un  CPE de l'Est
de Montréal.
ISABELLE THÉORET, Responsable en
Alimentation, CPE Bouton Éclair
- Si jcococococommandes,
souvent, je vais faire ça
le matin : la commande de fruits
et de légumes, la commande
pour le laitier aussi.
Après ça, il y a vaisselle
de la collation du matin,
et après, je commence
la préparation du diner.
- Le gouvernement  u u u u une
augmentation maximale de 20,2 %
aux éducatrices sur trois ans,
mais d'un maximum de
sur la même période pour
le personnel de soutien.
- J'ai étudié en technique
de diététique, c'est un coursoi.
Vu que ça fait 26 ans,
je suis en haut de l'échelon,
donc je suis payée 20,67
Dans les hôpitaux, aussi, il y a
des postes comme ça, mais dans
sont plus élevés pour les
personnes en alimentation :
autour de 26-27 $.
- Du côté des syndicats,e e e et
a fait des propositions
salariales intéressantes
prévues pour les autres corps dt
insuffisantes, en faisant valoir
beaucoup à la qualité des
servicesrdrdrdrdrdrdrderies.
CAROLINE SENNEVILLE,
présidente de la CSN
- Et nous ne voulons
Notre objectif, c'est que d'ici
la fin dveveveveveveve, on puise
aller voir nos travailleuses
en CPE pour aller chere e e e ee
illimitée.
SONIA LEBEL, Ministre,
Conseil du Trésor du
mais je trouve ça déplorable
qu'on prenne les parents
en otage, alors qu'oencore en pt
comprendre que la capacité de
payer, elle n'est pa
- Tu t'en vas où en avion?
- Marie-Noeioioioioioioioioioio.
Elle estime que les demandes
syndicales sont justifiées
et elle rappelle au gouvernement
que la lenteur des pourparlers
sur les épaules des parents.ese.
C'est pas toutes les familles
d'eux pour les aider.
mmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmigrants,
il y a des gens qui ont moins
d'aide que d'autres,
qui ont moins de chance,
il y a des grands-parents
qui travaillent encore.
prix à payer pour les parents.
- Malgré les appels à un vote
les discussions entre
les différents syndicats
des travailleurs de CPE
doivent se poursuivre
tout au long de